could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
basically that documentary became my own
therapy
she said he's gone
still such a weird thing that people
don't want to talk about but yet is the
biggest killer in men our age roman camp
is truly remarkable and deeply inspiring
it's all about creating
tools
you know in our brain to learn how to
deal with these issues your brain
becomes mike tyson and is just beating
you up and you've not had one boxing
lesson in your life so you just can't do
anything you're just taking it if you
had told me 10 years ago that would be
my job and that's what people know me
for
i honestly would not even know where
that would have even started i'm pleased
that i've got a good core friend group
around me i'm glad that i've got my
parents around me i'm glad that i've
gone out there and i've taught myself
the tools that i need to go and fight
mike tyson in there and and be able to
go up against him
and that's why i feel passionate to be
able to go and do that for kids now
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
roman
hello what were you like as a kid tell
me
as a kid i was
i'd say
verging on um verging on attention
seeker
and yeah always just performing i guess
i loved uh mimicking and like and doing
impressions and things like that like
when i first realized that i could do
impressions
i would do a non-stop and i would i
would go home i'd watch my teachers and
i'd say to my parents oh this is what my
teacher did today and i wouldn't just
say what they said i would
perform it for them
how they did it so i think i was
very much so like a high-energy
kid
i would say
verging on an adhd
kind of assumption but um
it was definitely a big change kind of
when i went through my teenage years
brothers and sisters
older sister 32
[Music]
very different from you
yeah but to be honest like she yeah she
is to be honest she she kind of she's
someone that her name's harley harley
moon
one word very pretentious parents
basically
doesn't necessarily mean anything i
think my parents were
must have been
slightly intoxicated after after the
birth and it was a full moon so they
named her harley moon but kids with
harley moon and roman at that time were
a little bit strange
so yeah just
no greater meaning other than the very
pretentious parents but um yeah she
she's
she's an amazing kind of person i i got
my work ethic from her from your sister
from my sister yeah
my mom and my dad are are
really supportive and and they're always
like
you know there in terms of like anything
i do is great
they're loving it i couldn't ask for
better parents but harley was the first
person i knew that
she went out at 15 and straight away 14
whatever it was was like i need to get
saturday job straight away like she was
the one doing it like she wanted to do
it she was asking my parents when can
she go and do it
and i used to be quite there's part of
me that was a bit jealous of that
because she kind of had this like
maturity quite early on
where she was making money and she went
out there and she became a
portrait photographer and then a big
celebrity portrait photographer and was
being hugely successful so she was that
person that i was like
i need to keep up basically
when you say i need to keep up basically
a lot of the stuff that i read about you
and your relationship with your dad in
particular um there was some it felt
like from reading what i read that there
were some issues with you feeling
um i guess not good enough because of
his because of the fact that he had been
so successful in his career
is that accurate
um
no yes and no because
to be honest i'm so again i'm so lucky
because the parents that i have are so
supportive of what i want to do and it's
the same way however they've parented me
is the same way i want to be with my
children you know i'm a massive family
person i believe that everything i'm
doing now is for is for my family and to
create better people
um
but i think with my dad and my mum in
that in that respect you know my mum was
part of the first group
uh
to ever um perform in asia do you know
what i mean like in terms of wham and
pepsi and shirley was insane you know my
dad part of spandau and acting career
and all these types of things
i'm insanely proud of that
so for me to then say i'm not good
enough for it or could never better it
puts a downer on those things i think so
i put it kind of in separate boxes i'm
not trying to emulate them
because in my head they will always be
my heroes i sat here with um eddie hearn
and a lot of people like uma from from
he runs pretty thing.com and his dad
obviously runs boohoo.com which is yeah
you know the founders and that they they
often spoke to that feeling of when
you've got successful parents it can
feel like a there can be thoughts that
creep in that make you think
um
often illogically especially in the case
of all those individuals i've described
that you've got you've got like a you
know a mountain to emulate all this you
know there's pressure yeah but that's
that's society like like i i always use
this as an example it's like you know
you look at um
you look at
any any famous kid like that there is
me myself being a an offspring of
someone who is famous two people that
are famous i will still look at you know
brooklyn beckham and see him getting a
scholarship for a photographer thing and
go ah but he's got like because of his
dad and i'll catch myself doing that and
then but that's a normal thing to feel
that's a normal thing to feel i'm sure
he hasn't i'm sure he's got great
talents but i i fully understand why
people would look at me and go oh he's
got to where he is because of his dad
let me tell you at the beginning i asked
my dad hook me up like help me out and
he couldn't like genuinely like that
because of what i wanted to do was
different
but i would say with with my dad it's
never it's never the pressure and with
my mum it's never the pressure of how
well you're doing and like you know tick
this off take this off look what i've
done you've got to do this this this
this this it's not that the hardest
thing with my old man and my mom for
that matter
is
the public perception of them is
how it is which is they are so nice
and like there are these amazing people
i always feel like for for me and my
sister there's more of a pressure for me
to be able to have a good relationship
and a wife the the in the way that my
dad has that for me is more of a
pressure than anything to do with work
the relationship that they have weighs
massively on me because i don't want to
ever go through a divorce i don't want
to ever you know go through problems
because they never did
so when people ask me that question i'd
rather like
i'd do anything to have their
relationship over their career yeah yeah
when you were that age say like 14 15
when you were thinking about what you
wanted to be when you grew up what was
your aspirations at that point
um uh kind of
i signed the record i signed a a record
deal
at 15.
um which came through in such a weird
way like like it was like
meeting people and someone's saying oh
would you would you want to try and do
would you want to try and do songwriting
and i'd have been interested in it and
i've worked with a few people worked in
management companies
as a saturday job
and then they were like
yeah cool let's do it and i signed a
development deal with universal music
which basically means you're
the label's [ __ ] right where you'll be
a part of any project that they want you
to be a part of
so they they basically own any output
that you have
and what you say you can do
i mean you got paid at 15 it was okay
and look at the same time i was being
able to sit in meetings with people who
are now heads of labels and and you know
meet all these people and kind of grasp
an understanding it's definitely helped
with me now having you know interviewed
so many artists in terms of what they're
going through because i've witnessed
some form of that
and i did that for
three years about three years from when
i was 15 to 18. hey listen when when i
signed up i signed a deal at 15 and then
i went in to do my gcses no wonder
they're bad at my gcses i couldn't care
less
i i literally i walked into some of my
gcses i walked in the room signed my
name and walked out
i got you in maths
because of my name
like like
i was distracted at that age and i kind
of guess
i knew i didn't know exactly what it was
but i knew that world was normal to me
and and
like the music world was normal to me
the film world was normal to me because
i've grown up in it
and i guess that's why i wanted to do it
it's never been anything to do with
fame
in our house do you know what i mean
like the idea of what you want to do
when you're older was never attached to
oh well i'll be really famous if i do
that
yeah what was your first sort of real
real job then
real job uh
yeah so no so i i basically i i did i
did universal for a while and and worked
with you know in a band and in bands and
projects or whatever right
and
i then reached a point where that all
ended like really abruptly
partly because i just couldn't do it
anymore and it was a lot i felt like it
was a lot to take in and i remember just
sitting with my mom and just like
i was like i must be 18 and i was just
crying i was just like i just
i can't be a part of this like this is
too much like the expectation on
young kids in the music industry is a
lot what was what was the well it's like
it's a lot you're putting in your own
emotional
being into you know music or into you
know this this kind of like thing i
guess the only way i can describe it is
how you know kids must feel if they're
young footballers and they're trying to
make it and they get cut from teams
it's a lot of emotion going up and down
and up and down you know you win at one
point and then the loss is so hard and
when you're going through puberty
imagine that at the same time you don't
know how to handle that and what were
they trying to make you into a
songwriter no so i was i was part of
bands
yeah yeah yeah they put me in bandsaw i
was you know bass playing or or it was
like oh would you want to write a song
for other people do you want to do this
this and that and don't get me wrong it
was an amazing experience and one that i
would still do now 100
i think that
again it's it's everything that i've
done obviously makes me the person that
i am now and gives me the ability to do
what i do now
um
and i i i just at that point had just
reached a moment where i was like i
can't do it anymore so and then i said
to my mom i was like i was like i need
to do something that is nowhere near
media and i'm just gonna go and get a
regular job every day and i ended up
getting a job basically just cleaning
toilets and cleaning equipment in a gym
near me
and i did that for about a year and a
half
and it was horrible
[ __ ] you know
a year and a half is it
it was it was it wasn't great it wasn't
great i went out there i did i got all
the what was it pt qualifications and
all that sort of stuff so that i could
work in a in a gym
but
literally it's just glorified toilet
cleaner essentially like i was just
cleaning cleaning running machines for
about a year and a half and then during
that time i kind of realized that my
creative side was like really struggling
in terms of like i couldn't
i've always wanted to create and do
stuff so i knew how to like edit
um film and i knew how to
film as well
and so
with my money from working at the gym i
went out bought dslr started filming
stuff and filming for friends and like
[Music]
rappers and
like grime music videos and things like
that just to make some extra cash and at
the same time like on the weekends i'd
just make my own stuff and i'd put it on
youtube and i'd just
have fun with it
you know i knew that world was
a world because
i was i'd come from a school where
i sat my classmate was ksi
but that in that moment you're like
so i know that's possible
and i think that's something that's so
important for so many people when they
know it's possible
and that's the problem with
you know sometimes that's where i think
people get stuck in
well worst case scenario worst case to
say is a class system
because they don't know
what you can do and what your potential
could go to yeah um
but you know i'd seen jj do it i'd see
time and do it and all those types of
kids and i was like you know what this
is this is an amazing thing that they're
doing
i'll give it a go and uh and from there
i will suddenly just kind of turn it
into this presenter role i guess
did you ever have an intention of doing
presenting no god no
absolutely not i would have been very
happy just doing camera
genuinely i love like i've always still
to this day i will stand by by this time
i'm 60 i would have at least uh directed
one feature film wow 100 you'll do it
100 no i know i'll do it because i'll
make it happen i don't care how low
budget it is but i will do it
[Laughter]
so how how
tell me about your first proper
presenting gig then and how that came
about there was a football company
called football daily i know them yeah
yeah
and so this was right at the start of
when they started out and uh
they were just a group of lads that were
just pushing out content
and i just had this idea for a for a
video
that was based on uh
like a football pickup line video
and it was just silly and they were like
well could you just go out and film it
for us and i was like yeah fine
and then they're like actually do you
want do you want to do you want to just
be in it and do it if that would be
because it's cheaper and quicker yeah
right so i was like okay i'll just go
out and do it
and then from that they then started
asking me to go on to like chat about
football i mean football something was
so massive in terms of my life
i'm an arsenal fan sorry about that but
how are you man united oh man where are
you from london
uh
i don't hear a man cuny an accent so
that's pretty many knighted um no so but
you know it's like
i i started doing like silly kind of
prank videos that then turned into
chatting but
it kind of all merged into one i ended
up getting gigs with
channel 4 mtv
capital were asking me to do like
outside broadcasty bits basically just
like for the breakfast show they'll go
let's cross over to roman who's at
wimbledon you know what i mean but those
are so important those every like you
know with presenting is is
is air miles is you you've got to do it
like and and you've got to do all of
those jobs because they throw different
challenges to you every time
you know
and and they will come back and you'll
look back and you'll go i'm so pleased i
did that really [ __ ] job
because
i know what i got out of it you know
there is no there's there's never a
thing as a bad job ever
because you will always get one thing
out of it whether that just solely be
i've done jobs i never want to talk
about everything in my life like in
terms of like how bad they were but
i learned that from them so the next
time i come to that point and i go hang
on this is one of them yeah so therefore
it was a good job to take i'm not making
that mistake later at that time in your
life did you
did you at that point have an idea of
what you wanted to do in the future when
you were doing the football daily stuff
and
ah
if i'm honest i i wanted to i just
wanted to be football presenting
because that's what i loved and i was
enjoying myself
i was i was happy
and i was at a point where i feel like
i'm getting paid to do something that
i don't feel like i should be paid for
you know and i think that's that's
always been
my focus always it always has been
am i happy doing it
yes
okay we'll keep on doing it
and i think that's the most important
with anyone my mom actually again it was
a conversation with my mum that she said
to me and she was like
what is it that you want to do and i was
like i don't know i don't know you know
i had so many things i was like should i
should i try and be an actor because
that's what
my dad did or should i try and do music
because that's what my mom and dad do
should i stay there
and then she was like no no but forget
about that what do you like love doing
like what makes you happy and i was just
like i don't know just chatting about
football with my mates she was like why
can't you chat about football and make
that your job
and i was like well i don't know anyone
in that and she goes well why can't you
just make your own stuff and show people
that you can do it how can i wish i had
a mum like yours man honestly like like
that's what i'm saying like but these
conversations are real conversations
that she had with me and she was
literally saying well you just have to
show people that you can do that i was
like well how am i gonna i can't just
walk into sky sports she was like why
not my mom really kind of again my dad
my dad is
too nice he's too good of a cheerleader
anything i want if i said if i said um
you know when i was working at the gym
or anything like that if i had said
i had to clean this treadmill today and
i think he goes yeah but i saw it and it
was so good
it was so good but that's what i mean
you know
the best parents i couldn't have lucked
out more you know if if we are living in
a matrix world where you select your pod
of who your parents are i have done so
well um but yeah my mum was the person
that was really like you know what what
is it you love
and
and i said that and she was like you
know create your job you know
make it and and i did and
you know she's my mom's very spiritual
in terms of manifesting and and i listen
i'm more a coincidence person but
um
yeah she i think my mum always my mum
always says this this one thing to me
which
i will have forever and i will always
teach to my kids and i think you know
going back to what you were saying about
that pressure of having parents that
do what i do
uh
you know and and we're all part of the
same world
having famous parents
the one word that people will constantly
say to you is that you're lucky
constant yeah it will constantly say to
you
oh yeah but you are lucky because you
got this or you got lucky because your
parents have this
and and i want to say to my mom i was
like i've just done this really cool
thing
and all people say to me is oh yeah but
you got lucky it's like so my mom used
to say to me she was like she was like
yeah but
break that down and you know break down
what what luck actually is and she was
the first person to say that phrase to
me where she said you know luck is when
preparation meets opportunity
and it's so right you know i i prepared
myself in terms of i went out and i did
the mileage i did all the rubbish jobs i
learned about football you know all
those types of things i spent those
hours
you know wanting to be the best i could
be at it and then it just so happened
that an opportunity in life of rose
where i could show that skill set
and from now on that's all i ever look
at like ass
you know and so when people say that i
was lucky on something i was like yeah
but i prepared to be in that situation
and it was
fake that the opportunity was there 100
i mean i even get that now people will
say to me that i got got lucky and
i always liked one particular example
which was when i i when i was 18 broke
kid up in manchester in moscow see
manchester yeah yeah
off in manchester and i was living in
moscow and i sent an email at 3am in the
morning
to the first person that came up on
linkedin asking if they'd invest in my
business and i was asking them for five
grand they replied within a couple of
hours and said they would if i'd if i
assembled the team
and i'm super lucky the first person i
emailed gave me five grand i was up at 3
a.m in the [ __ ] morning
yeah i showed the email on stage where i
removed the times the little thing
blocking the timestamp yeah and i go you
can call it luck but i know where you
were at 3am on that saturday morning
and so again but you created that
opportunity
and that's what i'm saying like that
that opportunity just was there yeah and
you had to have all the back knowledge
to be able to do to provide it so if you
just went to someone and said oh i want
that and then they were like well what
have you got to show for it you had
nothing they wouldn't have done it and
another another example that i actually
learned actually from when someone was
interviewing me the other day if i got a
dice and i rolled it a thousand times
eventually i'm going to get like 10 if a
coin let's say eventually i'm going to
get heads ten times in a row just
because i flip it a thousand times if i
flip 100 times it might happen but again
it's like increasing the opportunity
because of the amount of just flips
if if i had prepared in my life to do a
different type of job i'm sure there are
so many opportunities that i've missed
in this life that i'm living that would
have been better for a different man
that's basically how there's constant
opportunities especially when you know
that's why we're so fortunate to live in
a place like you know we live in london
like well i live in london you know i
mean it's so fortunate to be able to be
here and and you know not be in some
you know [ __ ] part town that's why i
always that's why that's to be honest
that's why i always love
uh you know i really like i really like
you know the kind of grime scene and the
the the rap scene in in the uk and all
that type of stuff because
these kids have come up from [ __ ] like
bad areas with no so low opportunities
and they've made tying of it you know
which is great so when do when did you
get a call from capital and how did that
happen
so
i had i had a call from them that was
like um
yeah can you come and do um
uh this was whilst i was doing i must
have been doing football daily stuff i
was doing stuff for like four music like
just little hosting bits online
and then someone called me and they said
um
oh you come and uh
do a demo like come in and just do like
a
quick let's hear how your voice sounds
so i was like yeah come in
did that thought nothing of it didn't
really hear back then a few weeks later
will you do some outside broadcasting
bits where i remember i had to go to
wimbledon
and chat to people
just in the queue rubbish like join me
right rubbish stuff but all air miles
you know all stuff that to this day i
still know exactly what they taught me
in
my first demo
and
after that it kind of went to a point
where i
they offered me a show that was like
they were like yeah you can do like bit
bit role shows so like 1am to
4am
on a weekend every two weekends
do you know what i mean and you're like
and
you know a lot of people are like you
know all my mates again were like well
graveyard shift but i was like yeah
but i'm off i'm gonna well to be honest
i yeah well that one that it was so
great because it because it was in the
middle of the night i could make any
mistake i wanted
no boss is listening so no one cares
right i could learn i've learned you
know all the buttons and all those types
of things i don't know like i know radio
presenters now that are like what do you
mean you do the buttons
yeah
yeah it's more fun like you know what i
mean so it's it
it was again it was that moment where i
had to learn and i knew that and i
wanted to learn the craft as much as
possible
and
with radio i kind of just accidentally
fell in love with it if you had told me
10 years ago i was hosting radio and
that would be my job and that's what
people know me for
i honestly would not even know where
that would have even started
crazy though which is odd and it's hard
because i get
you get a lot of
radio is a very
you know as i say it's a
clicky place because a lot of people
went to student radio and like you know
what i mean like those types of things
and i didn't take that natural path
to be totally honest with you i said to
myself i was like right i'm on capitol
now
this is when i was 22
yeah when i was 20 20 yeah 21 22 and i
said to myself i was like right
i'm doing 1am to 4am every couple of
weekends now within well in 10 years i
want to
be doing the breakfast show
and i did it in three
two and a half three
and like that for me is still like the
best
you know
achievement that i can name for myself
why do you think why do you think you
did so well on radio because i kept
pushing and i kept i kept like i always
like i speak to you know younger radio
presenters now or even presenters that
are there and i always say
what show are you doing all this type of
stuff and then they'll be worried to say
what i now say to them what show do you
want to do
and they won't want to say it because
there's someone else there but it's like
well
if you don't
you know what i mean like i was there
every single day i know every every
other week i was knocking on the boss's
door saying
i'm better than that person
i i can make it better i can do this
better i can this better you gotta do it
no one's no one no one owes you
something do you know what i mean that
no one owes you that opportunity to have
a better show or a better tv show or
whatever you know if i go to a
commissioner at a tv channel i sure as
hell have to go in there with a better
idea than what they've currently got
otherwise what's point being there
i'll sit there and go oh can you please
give me a show no
like i've got to prove that i've got a
show why
and and that's all i did on on on
capitol it was literally like i remember
they gave me
they they said to me there was like
there wasn't any show slots going and i
was like
what have you got and they were like
saturday five till eight
which was
a horrendous show slot because 5 pm till
8 pm which is like everyone knows that
is
dog territory how come like just because
it's just low ratings right people are
getting ready to go out you know i mean
on a saturday night no one's really
listening to the radio those types of
things not it's not quite 8 p.m where
you're getting getting doing pre-drinks
and those types of things so it's just
low rating statistically
and i was like i don't care give me the
show i was like i like you in the show
and then we took that and uh
me and and joe my producer when we we
turn we get we gave it the
the highest the highest
ratings
within that slot that there's ever been
for one
and it did some record in terms of
weekend numbers ever on capitol why
because we changed it we before capital
was always um
constant happy happy happy as quickly as
you can in between the song
say as little as possible move on move
on move on move on
i wanted to create a show where i was
like no that's not what
if saturday at five o'clock
is quite a dead period for
kids that were my age at that time which
was like 20 23
and i was like a lot of my mates are
these youtubers and these types of
things why don't i get some of them on
we'll just play some games we'll have
more fun with it
and we just kind of created this a vibe
you know instead of just going the
classic route
of what of what they wanted to do and
because it was a rubbish slot they just
kind of said to me try it out
and we tried it and and and did it you
know but it's just having that belief
and just being like bang on the door and
be like look
if it works it works if it doesn't it
doesn't take it off me
so
i'm pleased that we did that and that
kind of led to me then going into
like an evening show slot
quick one there is a really exciting new
product coming from here which the
founder julian told me about yesterday
on whatsapp um and it's something i've
wanted from hill for a long time because
when i look at my kind of nutrition
stack the things that i have and consume
every single day to keep me performing
at my best and in good shape and healthy
there's one thing missing which she'll
currently don't do and to get that
message from julian yesterday and to
know it's on it's on its way is
tremendously exciting
the thing about huel is they always
focus on a couple of core principles
which is making sure that the the stuff
inside the products are
not only nutritionally complete but
they're sourced from suppliers that
provide the best quality nutrition and
to know that you are now going into more
categories that are essential to my
nutrition stack is incredibly exciting
so if you're starting your fuel journey
or you haven't started your fuel journey
my recommendation is to get the starter
pack they have on the website i'll link
it down below and that gives you a
little bit of all the products in a box
and then from that you can decide which
products are for you and where they fit
in your life and i think if you're
anything like me you might just fall in
love with the brand
you went on to do a documentary which i
i watched which was incredibly moving
for a number of reasons um personally
i've got a you know one of my maybe my
best friend and my business partner for
the first seven or eight years was
um
was depressed as we were running the
business and i had no idea yeah so i
only actually found out in hindsight and
he said to me
when he came on this podcast actually
afterwards
after he had had a problem with alcohol
and i'd caught him in the laundry room
we lived together at like 3 a.m in the
morning drinking alcohol
and i'd because at the time i didn't
understand what mental health um
disorders were yeah so i just thought oh
he's got he's a piss-head yeah yeah you
know what i mean but obviously that's
i've come to learn that that's a symptom
yeah something um
and then it all came to a head one day
where he got really drunk and started
exposing himself in front of employees
it's a long story but um
then we had a chat and it was the first
time we had a chat about what was going
on yeah without like anger or
assumption and then he opened up to me
and we cried on some sunday in the
office and he started his journey to get
to seeing a therapist etc your
documentary was just
it was just exceptional for so many
reasons
can you can you take me through yeah
because i because i know that you're
you're working alongside your best
friend joe
at the radio um yeah can you take me
through
i guess the first question is um
did you know that anything was
at all no troubling joe
no
i i
never known joe for
since i started six years
six years straight being with that
person every single day almost like a
boyfriend
like that's that's like like we work
together every day we go out you know
all the time like like after shows all
those types of stuff weekends go out if
i had lined up
my favorite guys over 10
20 if i had 30 mates i'd say 30 mates um
i would probably put him last as to
who i would suspect would ever do
anything like that i mean to put it to
put it into context obviously
the documentary you're talking about
obviously being you know about
male suicide and and male depression it
was
even this world that i'm in now i i
really do not
wish i was part of this world
like in terms of like i wish i didn't
have people talking to me about suicide
but this is where we are it's how life
goes that's that's it um but when it
came to joe my my producer yeah he you
know he was the first person when i went
to wimbledon that day he was the first
person i met when i when i did my demo
for the first first time he was that
person that was there with me this is
someone that taught me everything i know
in terms of my professional being now on
in terms of radio
he taught me everything
and
sat next to me literally
two foot away from me
every day on every single show you know
laughter as i say go out together all
those types of things
but
i think
joe took his own life in august last
year
and that
for me was a moment where
i i kind of i
i had dealt with my own kind of
suicidal thoughts and my own kind of
depression and joe was very much aware
of that which is why it was so strange
to me and why i felt like i had this
piece of paper in front of me that said
everything you know about of what you
think you know about someone that is
suicidal in quotes is wrong
because it doesn't have any form of
symptom
because that's why each suicide is
different to the next and you can't you
can't nullify it you can't be like oh if
someone is you'll know someone's
suicidal because they'll look like this
this this this you'll never find those
answers
which is a scary thought
but it's also um you know like what like
what you said there like you didn't know
that mental health
that puts you in a higher risk category
than it puts me
the majority of men that take their own
life have no idea that mental health
disorders even
are a thing
most of them think that people are just
kind of
lying or or people are just attention
seeking when they say they have
depression
that's over 70
of men that take their own life are in
that situation they see it as a means to
an end
they don't like what's going on in their
life
how do i make it
stop take your own knife
it's it's it's so
strange so yeah so sorry in a
long-winded way i would never have
thought that joe would have been that
person at all now
that really does um
make you think about all your friends
right 100 but that's why that's why like
wow you know and look when when i when
it came to to making the documentary joe
died in august
i started making that doc in november
two months
right because i one all i know how to do
is
through
creative stuff i don't
my writing like you know what i mean i
write something down i'm not going to
lobby government because i don't know
how to do that you know all those types
of things
i just know how to make something and
and i knew also selfishly i knew that if
i do a doc
i'm going to be able to meet people that
have tried to take their own life i'm
going to be able to meet psychiatrists
i'm going to be able to meet professors
and learn the science because i was so
convinced in my head i was like
i need to know all the things that i
need to be looking out for
for my other friends yeah
basically that documentary became my own
therapy
and and people watched it and i think
that's why
you know i realized after that [ __ ] like
it is one it's everywhere
and two there is no
there's no way of telling so therefore
the only people that can help those
people are their friends
and that's what the documentary is it's
not a documentary about suicide it's a
documentary about friendship and how we
now have to take ownership of our mates
what did that journey of creating that
documentary and your own experiences
teach you about and this is one of the
things that's really fascinated me for a
long time is like we're seeing this
apparent increase in mental health
disorders and i say apparent because
sometimes it's hard to distinguish
whether it's because of the increase in
awareness that we have more people
putting the hand up and say listen i'm
suffering or it's because if the world
has changed social media whatever you
want to call it and people are we're
living in a less
healthy way but so we're seeing this the
data shows that there's a pretty
significant increase in mental health
disorders things like treatment
resistant depression i'm actually the
creative director one of the big
investment investors in a um a tie which
is one of the maybe the biggest mental
health psychedelics business in the
world so i do a lot of i have spent a
lot of time looking at clinical studies
and obviously psychedelics is it comes
that depression more from a place of
like what's happened to you versus
what's wrong with you yeah yeah yeah
it's about like ayahuasca and stuff like
that yeah yeah you're like yeah it's
more sort of like trauma-centric
approach to looking at
what have you learned about what's
causing the increase in mental health
disorders from your journey um
it's it's tough i mean i can only speak
from a male perspective um obviously
um and i only ever have done because
i i it's so easy and the thing the thing
that the most
the thing that i saw the most was
oh um
everyone's saying to me well it's social
media in it there's social media the
fastest is not like like social media is
there yes and and it and it can you know
create
a trigger or anything like that for
someone that
may be feeling down i don't think it's
the sole purpose i can also be madly
inspired by social media i can also be
made to feel really really happy by
social media
i think the main problem with men is is
purely down to
is is almost toxic masculinity so it's
our own kind of fault you know the
pressures that we put on ourselves
um
to to be you know the person that we
want to be to to to have the body that
we want to to have the things that we
want and to to have the job the family
you know even the pressure that i put on
myself to have the family that i should
have
you know i'm i worry that if i come to
like the age of 50 and i don't have that
how am i gonna feel
you know and it's all about
it's all about creating
tools
you know in our brain for kids as young
as five and and you know throughout
primary school to learn how to deal with
these issues throughout time like people
have had depression it's just how our
brains are worked
you know what i mean that's how our
brains and why there's always been
depression yeah you know you've got a
right point in terms of like the data
i'll obviously show
that there's more because there are more
cases don't get me wrong like throughout
the pandemic obviously
i always like i don't go too much into
to government stuff but i think it's so
like grotesque to even
trap people in their homes in the way
that obviously they did do and not think
about
the mental health side of things because
they haven't they completely ignored it
like like the government completely
ignored how much of a problem
mental health will be
during the pandemic people being on
their own not being able to go about
their lives you know and also the trauma
that that's going to have later on in
life for kids
you know i learned a stat though that is
horrendous right and this is something
that
you know when i was asked will i go out
and make another documentary and i think
for this
stat i want to
because i can't quite believe it
any business or any school has to sign a
health and safety declaration
right and that's how it is they all have
to sign a piece of paper that says if
you hurt yourself here
we'll sign that 100 of schools up and
down the country sign that
there is also a declaration of mental
health right where a school has to look
after a kid if the traumatic event
happens within school they have to make
sure that you know their their mental
health is looked after
in the uk
two percent of schools have signed that
so you're saying that 98 of schools up
and down the uk
look at mental health and go nothing to
do with us
school is the most traumatic time in
anyone's life if parents knew that if
parents knew that the
schools don't care about your kids
mental health
then that that is what is you know
that's what's putting us in a situation
now where men are killing themselves
because we don't know we've never been
taught how to deal with it no one's ever
looked after us
teaching us how to deal with it you talk
about toxic masculinity though one of
the things that's always associated with
that is just men's lack of willingness
to like
make a phone call yeah to a friend and
say listen i am
not okay and you know you also have been
very open about the day where you were
feeling like that and your
superwoman mother yes once again yeah
she she called you coincidentally or
yeah yeah yeah yeah coincidentally well
it was kind of like yeah i went to
caller and then like [ __ ] like i texted
her a couple times and then she just
called me
because you were feeling bad so you text
her
yeah i mean people are telling you this
but when you're in that zone
you know if you're in a
absolute spiral everything goes into a
right blur
all i know is that i was in my house and
i was in my pants and i was i could not
stop crying and i couldn't stop worrying
about everything and my head was going
like a whirlwind like
i was worrying about stuff that wasn't
even logical like what was your brain
telling you
i can't even like i can't even describe
it like it's like
the only way it feels like
anything in my head that could have been
a problem
was a problem have you ever had like you
know when you're you're hungover
and well like the next day i don't know
if you drink but yeah the next day right
if you have a hangover
you have this like paranoia thing like
throughout like stuff just makes you
feel a little bit edgy whispery like
yeah yeah yeah it's like that but a
million times the only way also that i
talk about it is like
it's like a paranoia and it's like
mike your brain becomes mike tyson and
he's just beating you up
and you've not had one boxing lesson in
your life so you're just kind of like
you can't do anything you're just taking
it right and it's like you're things
like you look bad you've not done this
your tax bill's this you're this you're
this you're this you're this are you
ever gonna do this you're never gonna do
this
loads of like voices
and at that point i just said to myself
you know what i can't
i don't know what to do and the only
thing i could think about was i was okay
well just
i'll just
you know
take my own life i'll just kill myself
that's that's how honestly how i felt
because i was like that's the only way
to stop this
and then as you said my mum called me
and uh she kept me on the phone for
about an hour because i was at my house
and i'd like in my head i was like i'll
just go to the train station and just
you know
do like you know take a jump right
between that's honestly what went
through my head and then it's like at
that point i was like okay
fine and then i speak to my mom and my
mum got there within
an hour and we just kind of
you know what i don't even remember i
don't even remember getting there
it's a very strange place to be it's a
it's a natural
you know break they call it a mental
breakdown for a reason because i can't
your whole mind just blanks and that's
that's the same thing that i've spoken
to a lot of people that have attempted
to take their own life and they all say
the same thing
those moments that you have are
completely like
just
so
intense that your mind goes
it implodes
and and you don't even know and that's
why a lot of men will will tell you that
when they
you know if they take it to that step
which is a huge step to to decide okay
i'm going to take my own life a lot of
men go
that was my happiest moment because i
felt like in that time i was in control
of my life
which is a really scary thought and
really sad thought
that they feel like the biggest amount
of clarity that they've ever had in
their life and the moment where they
felt at peace
was when they felt like okay i'm gonna
do this
and everything will stop
but the problem is is that that's not
the answer
and it's really not and when i speak to
you know in the documentary i speak to
joe's mom
keep in mind this is three months after
her son has passed away and she's had to
be told that her son who she's raised
has taken his own life
she she sums it up in such an amazing
way which is kind of touching on a very
dangerous topic of selfishness
around suicide which a lot of people
don't want to talk about but it's the
truth which is
suicide isn't necessarily a selfish act
by that person
but the problem is is that no matter
what pain that person is feeling in that
moment no matter what pain you're going
through in your head
or sadness
you do not get rid of that
by taking your own life all you are
doing is you are transferring it to
everyone around you and you are
transferring that on average 180 people
get um affected by one singular suicide
and and that is what you are doing
and
it's just the fact you know like for two
months i absolutely hated joe i hated
him after he died i felt quite cold
because i was just like
how could you do that
i felt like i i could you leave me your
mum your dad your sister actually do
that how could you let someone find you
like do you know what i mean so it's
it's it's it's in that that you realize
that
no matter how much that clarity is there
and you feel like you're escaping a
problem
you are passing that on to someone else
and that's what's left behind you and i
know for a fact that i know like i would
put so much money on that
if he was here right now he'd look at me
and say sorry i made a mistake
100
so much so so much i was thinking about
that so the first thing is my business
partner also said to me he wanted he was
considering jumping in front of a train
that's what he said to me in our private
conversations the other thing is just
this this um
it's really it's really hard for someone
who's not been through
what you're describing there what you
went through and evidently what joe went
through
to understand the
that place if you've not been there
that's this is why it's so valuable
and like i was thinking you know it must
as you kind of alluded to there you
didn't choose to for everybody to ask
you in every interview about this topic
but the the immense value that it's like
it's doing on someone like me who's been
fortunate enough not to be in that place
who can now unders from your description
there that mike tyson description can
now understand
that
how that must feel yeah but i can't but
i can almost but the the thing is the
thing is is what's better is because you
are in a higher risk category than me
yeah i know which is [ __ ] terrified
because but now that i've spoken to you
about it yeah and that you you're not
because because that's that's the
problem is that you know all of the guys
that i spoke to said to me they were
like
didn't think mental health was a thing
was a thing
didn't think what i was going through
was depression thought i was just
rubbish and just thought i you know i
wasn't where i wanted to be in life just
wanted that to end
that's the the realization of it you
know and again it's it's that thing of
you know it's a it's a topic that no one
really wants to talk about and is is
also why
i was so adamant
that
the worst okay this is the worst thing
right is if you're in that state
your mate's in that state right
the last thing he wants to do is talk to
you about that
so why
is
the kind of push always
oh if you're fairly depressed you should
talk
no
that's the last thing i want to do if
anything you're going to make me revert
more
right you're going to go back more the
the pressure should be placed on us as
friends
to to make that call and to make that
conversation happen with anyone that you
would ever suspect even if you don't
suspect it make sure
how sure are you how sure are you of the
people in your phone book or your close
friends that they're not thinking these
thoughts not sure enough but that's what
i mean so all you have to do is have
that conversation but that will take you
having that conversation i always say i
do a lot of talks for businesses about
mental health
and
um
i always leave it with you know go away
today
choose three people in your phone book
that you speak to regularly
and
ask them ask them are they okay but do
it twice you know and that's something
that i learned from a group of lads who
had lost their mate
they they now look after each other by
asking at the beginning of the
conversation are you okay have the
conversation and then just go back to it
and be like so tell me yeah
are you okay
choose three people do that two okay
rule on them and tell me that you
haven't found something new from at
least one of those people
it's fact right like it's so messed up
for us as a society
you know especially especially living in
living in london
like
you know which is just a horrific
but amazing place
you know
it's this beautiful you know cultural
place it's my home it's it's everything
but it is also a treadmill
and you go get on it and if you're not
on it you're you're not even in the
picture
and
that means that conversation
switches to
what do you do how can i profit off that
and the most important thing in a
conversation should always be are you
okay
when you say to your mates hey how are
you you go yeah i'm good glaze over it
like that
why is that not the most important thing
that you ask someone
and it should be it should always be and
and that's why for guys we forget that
so you have to go oh [ __ ] okay i'll ask
it again
you know and and that is you know be i
want people to to be the the hero to to
their friends that i know i wasn't to
mine because i know i wasn't and no
matter how many people say to me ah he
did what he did because of you know that
was his prerogative and all that sort of
stuff yeah for sure but the fact is that
if someone had this conversation with me
i probably would have brought out with
him
and i would have i know if i'd if i'd
got to the crux of it if i'd if i had
asked joe those questions if i had said
to him
are you okay if i'd done that twice if
i'd spoken to him seen how he is
i don't think i'd be here
i don't think i'd be having this
conversation
and i want other people to understand
that it's up to us as friends
but you spoke to joe about your
struggles about me and did he ever did
he not ever reciprocate and say well
i've also been no no
but that's that's that's his that's his
thing what was he like as a guy in terms
of being a kid
was he was he a a
a guy that talked about deep topics like
you've got your friends yeah yeah was he
talked teachers
it's ridiculous like i still find it now
ridiculous even talking about him
because it's like if if he had known
that i was out here talking about people
about him
it's odd it's odd to be able to be
speaking about one of your friends and
like i don't know it's odd but he's
someone that was the most outgoing funny
creative guy he always he cheated on
genius and idiot
constantly
um he would have the most
ridiculous ideas and at 99 of them
you know i have 100 of them 99 would be
ridiculous and one would be incredible
and and that one incredible thing is the
thing that we'd always champion and push
forward but
he's someone that yeah like i say like
every single one of my friend grew i've
never noticed a more smiley person i've
never known someone
more happy-go-lucky more
just
happy to be there
and
that's why i say
if that can happen to him
best believe it can happen to anyone
else
did anybody ever find out
what got him to that place or any any
did he not leave him
no
again this is another thing is hollywood
would make us believe that people leave
notes yeah they're not over 90
don't
and and never know
and and that's why it's just a it's a
horrible horrible harsh thing
and it's it's so
final
that's the that's the problem is it's so
final also another thing is you know
girls can't be taken out of this
conversation as well because
when i i worked with the nottinghamshire
um
street triage team who are an incredible
team of people that are
police and mental health expert that go
out on calls together
so be a mental health nurse right with
with a police officer and they will
respond to
a mental health crisis right so someone
trying to take their own life etc
and i said to them i was like oh you
know i went there like
in the mode of like oh yeah so it must
all be guys that you speak to and then
we're like no actually it's around 90 of
our calls are women
having mental struggles
or trying to take their own life
and then you look at the data and you're
like why does that make sense but the
problem is is that us as men being
men we choose more final methods in
terms of
how to end that pain
and that's the unfortunate reality of it
you made that documentary it was i mean
it was it was everywhere and everybody
was talking about it yeah really really
far-reaching in fact i know that the
amount of people calling suicide and
sort of mental health um support lines
shot up drastically so it was amazing
it's like 700 percent or something crazy
like that yeah 720
um
but with that
you then carry this
i guess this like social you you become
the ambassador for something right i do
not want to be the ambassador for it but
that's how life is now
and the only reason why i'll go out
there and do it is because of joe's
family genuinely
like
it's not easy right talking about that
no it's not like i'll give you examples
like
you know
i'll go to parties now and you like the
main thing that like lads lads will come
up to me and talk to me about is how how
they feel
which is nice in a way
but it's a lot it's a lot yeah i won't
like that it's a lot it's a lot like
like there are days where i i don't want
to talk about i have people like again
like i'll be out for dinner or something
like that and someone will come up to
you and say oh my god that documentary
blah blah blah i wasn't thinking about
mommy taking his own life but now i'm
thinking about it
do you know what i mean but that is life
like that that's always how it is and
and the only way that i can kind of get
around that
is by
you know you can tell them but by the
way that i talk about it i'm still
passionate about it you know because
i've been scarred by
i've got such trauma attached to
suicide and and mental health and that's
a trauma that i'll always have you know
that when when you look for things
you know one of the questions i've asked
you know other people
you know that have been through what
i've been through
i said to them when does it get better
and and their reply is
it doesn't you just learn to deal with
it a little bit better
do you know what i mean like it you just
learn a different technique to stop
thinking about it
and
you know that will be with me forever
i'll tell my kids about joe you know
i'll be bang on top of my kids is mental
health you know what's going on with him
but again i just think it's
throughout all of this
you know as you say
being a part and having these
conversations now
is is crazy
and weird
do you still feel a bit of anger
sometimes towards
joe for doing that
um
yeah every now and again
every now and again that's normal yeah
you know it it's normal every now and
again i'll be like
every now and again it's more so like me
and my mates will have a story
and we'll laugh and then at the end of
it we'll go
like
why mate come on like because i know
like i know that if he was there what
he'd say to me yeah i can hear it clear
as day
he'd say i'm sorry mate i made a mistake
and and that that's what's so sad and
it's like i know that whatever it is
that he was going through it ain't worth
and it never is worth no matter what
anyone's going through is that this this
this is not an option
it's not an option
i've i'm mistaken because i can't
remember her name so please forgive me
if she ever hears this or friends of her
ever hear this um
there was a mum that that recently um
got the wording changed around um the
phrase commit suicide
so now that that is not a phrase that
should necessarily be said so it's
always you would refer to it as take
take your own life
because to commit suicide is actually an
illegal act
and therefore a lot of young a lot of
parents were left with a child who if
they had written it down that they'd
done that that they would go down
essentially as a criminal a criminal
because you're committing an illegal act
um
so that phrasing has gone now which is
quite nice is a nice thing
um
but you know
suicide is still such a weird thing that
people don't want to talk about but yet
is the biggest thing you think how much
think how many cancer adverts think
about testicular cancer adverts you see
on a daily basis now
put that together with how many male
suicide adverts do you see
you don't it
how have you
found being in the public spotlight you
talked a little bit about there about
like people coming up to you at dinners
and parties and stuff yeah yeah like
when you're in the spotlight anyway
people come up to you and just say oh i
love your thing yeah right but now
they're coming up and saying how have
you found all of that
in terms of the the dark the dark blue
just generally i mean in general mate
like to be totally honest i don't know
any different yeah genuinely because i
like
it for me it was uh
it's like
in the same way that i could say to you
how is it
in that bit how is it hitting puberty
it's like you'd seen people above you go
through that so you kind of knew what to
expect oh okay and you kind of dealt
with it do you know what i mean whereas
like for me because i was
people coming up to me now saying oh can
i get a picture and if i'm with a mate i
have to say to them
can you hold the phone and you know take
the picture
i was that person oh right holding the
phone half my life yeah you know so
it just it's always been always been
there any time i was a kid any any time
i was a kid walking into a pub going to
a football match walking into a
restaurant
anywhere i clocked people looking at my
dad
or my mom did you understand that they
were
like famous yeah mate loved it yeah i
loved it loved it like like put it this
way my sister was always my sister was
always
really shy my sister was always really
shy of it and my dad always tells a
story where he said it was a
show-and-tell
at school
and um i must have been about
six my dad was in eastenders you just
joined eastenders and um
his character name was steve owen in
eastenders right and um
and it was a big thing that he was in
there
and
the firemen came to school like to show
the fire truck and to you know show how
this is our equipment and all that type
of stuff
and they said any questions
and my dad and my mum said i put my hand
up
and said you may think that's cool but
my dad's steve
owen so i've always i've always been
insanely proud of my parents you know
like and and you know i credit them for
you know my dad has always been very
patient with everyone and in terms of
like
people wanting pictures or stuff like
that he always does it too yeah he
always does it but he taught me
something else which you know we had a
little bit of a chat about this before
but
he's never let me take pictures with
people
ever and i don't do that and i always
get i get told off about it because
people are like oh if you're hanging out
with this person you take a picture oh
so if you yeah so if you want to take a
photo with like justin bieber then he's
not gonna yeah even footballers right
like when i was a kid all i wanted was
was like you know take picture if i met
football i would want to take a picture
and he was like nah
enjoy that moment with you and that
person the picture is nothing you you
know it's great gratification for
someone else to see it he goes that you
should enjoy that moment live it with
your eyes and and and speak to them and
if you really want to you know make a
moment in that person's life go up to
them and say you know you know what i
really really like your work i really
appreciate what you've done i really
like this that goes so much further
than you know if someone came up to me
and said i just want to let you know
that i've really liked what you did that
means so much more than anyone's running
up to you and going
get a picture take a picture run off
yeah yeah you know if someone came up to
and said mate i really love your podcast
i really love you know everything you've
done the business the businesses that
you've created means so much more yeah
um someone was pleased about that so
yeah so so fame in terms of for me has
always kind of been um there's pros and
cons to
our jobs now
fame is a con
is a is a bad part of it
the good part is that we get to do fun
stuff
interesting
you the good part is you get to speak to
interesting people yeah sat here
the the con is that when you're out for
dinner someone may have watched that
conversation yeah and want to interrupt
you yeah and talk to you about it yeah
i went to i was went to the like united
away game the other day and i always get
it in some certain places so like
whenever there's a younger demographic
dragons is going to change that i was
talking to my team this week because
yeah like bbc one's a slightly more
parenty audience really change that
you'll see that so when i'm in my when
i'm at old trafford in the like gallery
area which is all probably a little bit
older people yeah no one bothers me
forgotten if i go to an away day
honestly last week someone had their arm
around me the whole game i love you
share me on his phone i love your
podcast yeah and i'm if he's going to
watch the game yeah come on he's out and
he's and you know anything yeah yeah
yeah i'm wearing a [ __ ] hoodie and
like
you know but yeah but that's why
it was a good thing in that sense yeah
it was a really good thing no it's
actually a conversation i started having
and you've experienced this much more
than i have which is just
i
will there become a point where i become
more of an introvert and don't want to
go to places because of the amount of
people that are like it's exhausting
right and i don't want to be i'll never
be an [ __ ] i know that for sure i'll
never say
it's tiring right it's tiring
for sure but naturally that will happen
because your life changes like you're
going to be on a tv show that is watched
by millions of people like like this is
that's
you know it's what my dad what my dad
always says you know and that's you know
that's why he always says to me you
can't you know people that get angry at
fans or whatever and like you know or
rude to people you can't put your head
above the parapet not expect to get hit
yeah you know what i mean like how can
you do that like
you're choosing to to go on a show that
is watched by millions of people yeah so
therefore if you go out you need to be
more careful you need to you know like
you know
understand that that people are going to
want certain things and that's fine but
that's just that's just the world
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast is one of
the brands that make that transition
much much easier they are at the
forefront of british renewable ecosmart
technology and their products are really
really changing the game if you're on
youtube you can see what i'm holding in
my hand this is called the eddie right
it's the uk's number one solar powered
diverter so what is a solar diverter
it's a device for people like you and me
that means you can divert your excess
energy back into your home rather than
back into the grid which will save you
power and money it's super user friendly
and easy to install and you can control
it using the my energy app on your phone
to find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
you've met a lot of very um
famous supers mega stars and you've
parted with a lot of them and been very
close to a lot of them i've been reading
some of the stories about justin bieber
when you look at some of these people
yeah that have been wildly successful
yep
what what have you noticed about like
their happiness and like the ones that
are happy the ones that you think oh god
i'm concerned for this one what is the
what's your general observation these
really happy people
honestly i think it's it's all about
it's all about the values it's always
about what are they doing it for
you know and
and
the family life
you know there's there's people that
what i always find so interesting is is
i think one of the reasons why i'm able
to again
do the job that i do and speak to
those people who are on such higher
pedestals
it's because you've got to remember that
i've grown up with a with a godfather
who is
or was
and still to this day one of the most
famous singers
ever in george michael
and
growing up with george i saw very
quickly that the more famous you get it
does not become more fun
it doesn't
you don't know who's your friends you
don't know those types of things and i
think that
that can lead people to
be into a bit of a troubled situation
you know you get approached by
so you don't have a good core friend
group like a big core friend group
that could lead to everyone around you
being yes men
that just want to be on the payroll that
will do something because
they think that it will help in their
career and those types of things
i'm uber fortunate i've got a really
nice friend group and the artist that i
know
you know speaking from a music music
background the artist that i know that
have those incredible friend groups are
just amazing people like ed sheeran
yeah it is incred like but ed's values
are so correct you know and his his
parents are lovely people as well in
terms of you know
the pleasure of you know having dinner
with his dad and stuff like that
[Music]
they
they're just people that
understand that this is just fun the
creativeness is just the fun you know
all the fame and those types of things
are just a side note you know ed ed does
everything he does now i'm sure because
he's he's so family orientated and
that's so important you know he's
married to cherry who's his childhood
sweetheart you know
give me another example it's like
not a horrendous one my good mates
niall's friend group is all his
friend group from
young school
young
and they will kill him like in like
conversations or like i mean his cousins
will rip him to shreds and all those
types of things and all it does is just
ground him constantly
and and it's that grounding nature that
if you don't have that within this world
or that world
you're gonna struggle
justin for instance was someone that was
taken at like nine he didn't have a
chance to to build a proper friend group
didn't even have a chance
and so you worry for people like that
because you know that's why you know he
he's now found faith and that's his
thing and and
that is his
grounding
moment in his life and his wife of
course she's uh exactly she seems to be
a good actor that's what i mean so it's
you know for him he has those things
for me is those core group of cool
grouper mates
and you must meet a couple that you're a
bit concerned about in terms of always
because i've met a couple of you know
famous people and i thought [ __ ] oh
they're not happy no you know 100 uh
could you feel it when you meet them
with their energy and then all the time
instantly
there's there's a few people that
you know i don't even know that well and
i've ended up having to reach out to
because i feel like
i probably should
and
it's sad it's a really sad like
sometimes it can be a sad existence
money can make you feel amazing 100 it
can buy happiness but that happiness can
run out like that's the thing as quickly
as your bank balance can run out that
happiness can run out like
and
people struggle like people really
really struggle and it's and this is
again this is another thing what what i
learned with making the doc about
suicide and talking about you know
mental health was
the first thing i saw when um
when people
uh
heard like press release came out saying
that i was doing a documentary about
suicide
or twitter was like
what what does a celebrity kid know
about struggling and
mental health and these types of things
but the thing is is that it's all you
know those struggles that you see
artists going through or you know
addiction problems or those types of
things
it's all just
it's only relevant to what their life is
you know those problems the problem that
someone in a lower class system has in
their head
will be just as high as someone in a
upper class system because
it's just
relevant to the circumstance
and it's big in their head and that's
what people have to understand is that
no matter what the problem is you know
people say oh it's a
an awful class problem or whatever
like
they like first world problem that's
what people say right
it's not that that's not to be looked at
it's it's just something that that's
what's affecting you
and you don't wear a uniform for
depression there isn't a
job title for depression yeah
you know one of the things you said at
the start this conversation was about um
one of the expectations that you do feel
a bit of a bit of pressure to me is the
one in
your sort of romantic life right yeah
i've struggled with that for a long time
i've got to be honest yeah struggled
with their girlfriend's dating all that
stuff tinder all of the way that people
date in the modern age and just like
finding good people and really putting
the effort in because i can't be
bothered with the small talk yeah yeah
yeah so tell me about that are you a
single man right now i'm single right
now yes yeah i just to be honest it's
it's like
my my one thing that i struggle with and
i've i've had girlfriends that
you know in the past where i've i've
i've been an absolute [ __ ] and of
course like do you know what i mean like
and i've let work get in the way i've
let that lifestyle kind of get in the
way but the one thing i know is that
i
i want
that
relationship i see my mom and dad have i
want that like more than anything you
know and i just
i think the thing that i panic about
more is
you know it's it's an odd thing but it's
like like for me
i think it's an insecurity that a lot of
men have that never talk about as well
which is
will i be able to have kids when i'm
older people never talk about that but
like i never hear any of my talk about
that but i'm always like oh that's my
biggest fear someone says what's your
biggest fear that
because i think that my sole purpose on
this life is is just to make other
people that are nice
like that's how i feel so you know for
me is i'm such a family person
i feel like at this point in time i
worry that if i got into something would
i be able to give that person what they
deserve in terms of being a partner
because i am
work focused and i do like i'm enjoying
my life right now i'm enjoying doing
what i'm doing and i don't want to like
defer from that have you struggled when
you're in a relationship and if so what
is the what is the in your sort of
self-aware opinion what is the reason
why you struggle in relationships um i
struggled in relationships in the past
and i still will struggle now going
forward because i always have this
massive fear that there is resentment
on
my future partners
part i mean i i never i couldn't be with
someone that
doesn't
really work or do those things because
i'd be so scared that they'd look at me
and think oh well it's fine for him
because he can
get this or afford this or do this and
this and this do you know what i mean i
always try my best to to make sure that
i'm with someone that i can raise up as
much as people on the outside raise me
up you know because that's that's a
horrible thing that i see so much and
look i go through it even now like you
know people come up to me and they go oh
my god your dad is such an amazing
person blah blah blah do you ever think
about you with your dad and with you
with your dad and all this type of stuff
and i'm like my mom is wicked like do
you know what i mean and that i think
that worry that i always had with my mom
and i always felt like i had to stand up
for my mom and be like hang on she
played at live aid as well do you know
what i mean she had a number one record
as well
i always feel like i worry that you know
about that in a partner and i want to
always make sure that a partner knows
that that no matter how many people are
coming up to me and saying oh you know
you're doing really well doing very well
i'll always be there and say yeah but
she's doing this
that's so interesting you know what i
mean
you know what i i don't because i've not
i've not been through that yeah but
that's that's what i mean that's that's
the thing that i think is so important i
see so many [ __ ] people
like and i've seen it my whole life
right
the celebrities that you they introduce
themselves to you or you you speak to
them and their partner just stands there
and they don't even introduce them to
you and you must have seen that growing
up because that that feels like it's
very front of mind for you whereas like
yeah yeah for sure people just don't
want to talk about that but it's like
you know it's a partnership you know my
that's always obviously my dad and my
mum now
fine but like
i don't want that i don't want my
partner to feel like everyone just wants
to talk to roman
i don't want that like i i really don't
and people and or for my partner to
think
what i do isn't as good as what he does
or doesn't earn as much money as what he
does or doesn't you know get as much
gratification as he does does that mean
that you go for
no it means that like i i i have i love
like women that have their
you know life going on or like are busy
or those sort of things that attracts me
more than anything
you know you look at the girls that i've
dated in the past that they're girls are
doing their own thing and they're
looking good at it like and you know and
it's one of the reasons to be totally
honest with you it's one of the reasons
why i don't really say english girls
ever i love someone not knowing what i
do for a living i love someone not
caring at all if i was to ask one of
your your two last exes if i said why
did your relationship with roman end
what do you reckon they'd say
um
two focus on work too focused on what
he's doing
um
i'd say that
that's interesting i i was that guy for
a long time maybe stalam yeah but there
but there's nothing wrong with being
that and that's that's what i have to
learn there's nothing wrong with being
up because if if you are happy in your
life if if you are
you know getting that fulfillment which
i feel like i am
then that's okay
there's a time for everything yeah i i
see it for me it was like a chapter so
there was a phase of my life where i was
very very very selfish but i always
wanted romantic connection in a
relationship i started to actually learn
the importance of it studying some stuff
and seeing that men that had a romantic
partner for their lives were lived like
several years longer got ill way less
and i was thinking okay maybe having a
relationship business is equally
important as just making millions of
pounds
and then i started to feel i don't know
you get older you've had a lot of sex
with a lot of people that you just can't
remember yeah and you thought well that
wasn't it that didn't feel yeah the day
after so
okay this is more substantive to have a
meaningful relationship and then
i've started to realize that okay this
is only ever going to work if i
compromise a little bit sometimes
and also find someone worth compromising
for yeah but a relationship is all about
a compromise yes that's it
it's always about compromise and it's
about finding someone that is your best
friend not not about you know someone
that you just find really fair are you
compromising do you think
um
at the minute i'm not because i i i feel
like at this moment in time and i'll be
totally honest with you
after
um
after i lost joe after joe did i i kind
of got in this mindset where i was like
you know what i just need to live my
life i just need to do what i want to do
and not feel like if i i didn't
personally i didn't want to get into a
relationship because i felt like some of
my
relationships or some of the moments
that i've been with people i feel like
i've wasted my time yeah and i can't not
feel like that so many people so many
girls feel like that about guys that
they've made i'm sure that this is this
podcast
and and i felt like that too and i felt
like you know what why was i
trying to compromise when i need to
enjoy myself a little bit you know and
find that kind of happiness and i firmly
believe that that time will come i'm
definitely a relationship person 100
yeah but and you know i believe that
time will come but right now i just know
that
it's more so in my head it's like
i know that i could get into seeing
someone or whatever but i just know that
it'll reach a point where i can't give
them what they deserve and a girl
doesn't deserve to have someone that
might be too tired that day to even text
them yeah yeah do you know what i mean
yeah yeah like and i'm someone that
likes my own space so it's hard so
looking forward to the future then one
of the things you said earlier was that
you are the type of guy that like knocks
on the door of your boss's office and
says listen i want that show this is
what i want
so tell me what it is that you want
looking forward professionally in your
in your future
my my
as to where i am right now i'm very
happy where i am right now
like very happy
therefore i'm not urging myself to to
knock on any doors genuinely
there are things that i feel passionate
about which i really feel like i'm going
to make this and i want to make this
going back to you know
schools and mental health which i think
is a really important thing and i have a
platform and
to be able to do it so
i will do that
i think the common question i always get
asked is
oh yeah so what's the next step tv and
it's like
no
it's i'm 28 years old and and i've got
in my opinion the best job
in the uk i get to wake up every day and
and
feel like i'm back at school
waking people up every day
that time will come that pressure that
i'll put on myself to go and find the
next thing or to think about where i
want to move next will come later on
right now i'm in a genuine position
where i love what i do i get up at 3
o'clock but second i'm there i'm happy
and and enjoying it
and i don't feel like
you know we spoke about this earlier on
as a
as a presenter like if i came out a
radio tomorrow
i'd be worried i'd be thinking oh [ __ ]
have i been on tv enough this month have
i have i tweeted enough have i done
instagram enough like
i i love the fact that my job now i
don't have to think about that
i don't have to post on instagram if i
don't want to because i've just spoken
to seven million people that week
do you know what i mean and and been
with them through a journey every single
day the pandemic was an amazing thing
like in terms of
i remember i had two weeks
two weeks holiday in april
2020
and i was going to take it
and my dad called me he was like you
can't
i was what do you mean you can't go on
holiday he was like this is this is like
the most important time
that you will ever have
to
to to you know
be with people and go through this with
them you can't just walk away they're
relying on you to do that this is your
responsibility to do it you actually got
quite angry because it was just like
that is your responsibility to do that
to provide some form of normality for
those people
and um
and so i did and you know throughout the
pandemic it was you just we created
these relationships with people that are
working you realize how much radio means
and you
you create friendships with listeners
and with people up and down the country
that you meet
and that to be able to go in every day
and so it's my job is an amazing thing
and i really truly genuinely love it
in the spirit of one of the things you
said to me during this conversation
now that we've been talking for a little
while i feel like i have to ask you yeah
how are you doing
i'm doing all right i'm doing all right
there are bad days there are bad days
where you know you kind of
you kind of think you know did i really
want to be in talking about
suicide do i really want to be going
over a trauma that's in my head
you know do i
want to sack in the whole job and and
just i've got enough money now to live a
knife nice little life somewhere quiet
and just go and do that
but
i think
those are all kind of moments in my life
that are you know moving forward and
like you said like i think
there's so much
more life for me to learn i think that i
am happy if i think about it i am happy
i'm i'm proud of the things that i've
achieved
you know
little things little things that i've
achieved you know whenever people ask me
what am i gonna do in five years i'd
rather say to them well this is what i
did five years ago
the last five years would look pretty
decent so i'm comfortable in my
you know ability moving forward
you know
i think that
i'm definitely tired which is one thing
always tired what do you mean by that
always like tired in a physical fatigued
way okay which getting up at 4 30 will
do to you
um
but no i'm okay as i said
there's updates and there's down days
but
those down days i'm pleased as well that
i've got a good core friend group around
me i'm glad that i've got my parents
around me i'm glad that
i've gone out there and i've taught
myself the tools that i need to go and
fight mike tyson in there and be able to
go up against him
and
that's why i feel passionate to be able
to go and do that for kids now
we have a closing tradition oh yeah
each guest that comes on the podcast
writes a question for the next guest
inside of the diary of a ceo so um
okay
how could you be more authentically
you
uh by being off my phone
i'd say
and i mean that just because when i did
i'm a celebrity get me out of here
that was
the happiest i've ever been
easily
in in there i was row which is what my
friends know me as
that was me
like
this here
is someone who
has to work has to do all these types of
things and and that and has all these
other sides but there i didn't have any
phone no expectation no nothing i
completely forgot the cameras were on
you all those types of situations
so so
for sure the more i can
stop working and enjoy moments without
work that's how i could be more
authentic than me
interesting
thank you so much honestly roman you
know um
you know i
the amount of um
the amount of value that your
openness to do what you're doing and i
see it as you are like doing a service
for society
and especially because of the
the
horrific nature of the statistics
surrounding like mental health and
suicide i can't tell you even for me
what this conversation has done in terms
of opening my eyes yeah and like i know
like so i just i guess what i want to do
is i just wanted to thank you because i
also
i don't envy and i'm going to be honest
i don't envy the position of people
coming up to me all the time and talking
about a topic like that yeah i find it
hard just even now people talk to me
about oh here's my business idea
yeah yeah yeah i'm sure and sometimes i
open my dms and i'm having a good day
working out and then i'll see a message
which is very which is of a similar vein
which is
very very tragic and it will just push
me off a little bit yeah so for you to
to choose knowingly to put yourself in
the position
of being a
involuntary advocate like the ambassador
of this this topic
is such a selfish do you find it hard
saying suicide
you do
there's a little part of you that's not
yourself
it's so weird it's not a swear word when
i first did the documentary when i first
did the documentary sorry to cut your
phone no you know
please please continue afterwards tell
me how great i am but but but when i
first started making the documentary i
felt like
you know
we're going to talk about today we're
going to talk about
it's weird but it's it's a normal word
it's it's life it again it's the biggest
killer for in men our age like suicide
is a very normal word it makes you feel
uncomfortable doesn't it yes
and that's what has to stop
but i just could see in your eye there
yeah i was thinking about these dm's and
i'm thinking i'm an ambassador
suicide sounds you're not suicide it
sounds like it's a really
emotional word yeah so with emotional
words we tend to you know use them
sparingly yeah but i was just intrigued
because it is something that i
had let me finish off just
no but i genuinely mean that from the
heart like it's it's what you're doing
as i said i don't envy it's not easy but
the
tremendous i think service it's doing to
society at a time when we need it the
most and we need people that are willing
to to have those conversations and be
honest because a lot of men are are
still caged is it's like impossible to
quantify i don't think you'll ever get
to see the good you do but i just want
you to know from my perspective and just
on me personally from seeing that
documentary that oh god if i can't think
of many greater goods that someone can
do for men in this day and age so thank
you as a man but as just as a citizen of
society as well thank you well i very
much appreciate that and thank you uh
for forever being on your podcast thank
you so much from roman appreciate it
[Music]
oh
[Music]